hola qué tal les habla pablo gómez
barrios y es un gran placer estar con
ustedes este mediodía hoy en la represa
cibernética con leonora chapman rufo
valencia y leonardo gimeno les
presentamos el castor cibernético de
este viernes 16 de noviembre en vivo y
en directo por facebook live youtube y
en nuestro sitio internet
rc y net punto se a un caluroso saludo a
todas y todos y bueno pues estamos
enviándole todo lo mejor para los que
nos están escuchando y oyendo gracias
por su agradable compañía
leonora rufo leonardo bienvenidos
igualmente pablo y hola a todos
hola a todo el mundo que tal bienvenidos
un saludo a todos en todas partes y en
todas y a todos en todo el mundo ruso en
todo el mundo
fuera del sistema solar las señales
viajan
así es a lo mejor por allá y además de
los amigos de prisma están algunos
extraterrestres por ahí tratando de
saber que por ahí alguien alienígenas
alienígenas y por qué me está esta
teoría de ese objeto hallado que es en
la forma de un puro
y que no es no corresponde a las
formaciones supuestamente normales de
objetos en el espacio y la conclusión
que llegaron científicos es que es muy
probable que sea efectivamente un
artefacto una nave hecha por otra tipo
de inteligencia si utilizaba la la luz
del sol como motor aunque sea la energía
y para darle peso porque es realmente lo
que le dio peso a esa información aparte
de esa fotografía que yo no sé cómo la
luz forma no sabes cómo lograron tomarla
esta fotografía a cuántos millones años
de distancia estaba no tengo idea pero
harvard dijo que era un objeto no
identificado entonces como es hardware
ya sale la información salió así
y efectivamente parece que no estamos
solos no es puro cuento parece que no
hace dos semanas
supuestamente como como es largo no es
ancho singular como un habano más o
menos como dice y el material es algo me
hace acordar un poco la película débil
nada esa película que hizo del espacio
algo me hace acordar a esa película no
sé si el material que había dentro
cuando uno entraba esa esa nave no me
acuerdo yo como no lo entendí no
[Risas]
la extraordinaria esa película muchas
escenas y se hicieron también en la
provincia pero la universidad de
montreal efectivamente agua luna tomó la
genialidad del de digna de edad de hacer
ese tipo de nave que uno nunca nunca vi
yo nunca vi algo parecido entonces las
naves espaciales que vienen de afuera
digo son extraterrestre las hacen
parecidas a las nuestras sí claro esa
quiso brindar no se parecían nada de la
vida inteligente que había
[Música]
logró comunicar ese proceso fue examinar
es increíble esa es la historia de
descodificar el lenguaje aparte de eso
tienen otras noticias e insólitas en
realidad dos menciones especiales una la
desaparición física stanley excelso
exención para el señor que se nos fue
que descanse el creador de cientos de
oficios en los x-men solamente cuando un
increíble
el doctor inyector los vengadores los
cuatro fantásticos ironman
elástico así que no están aquí la
expresión la desaparición física también
de la voz de hal 9000
[Música]
falleció también esta semana así que
también una mención para él y una cosa
me llama la atención se redefine se
definió el kilogramo porque ya no son
1000 gramos sino sigue haciendo
miligramos pero lo que pasa es que la
referencia a la física ahora es un
algoritmo 1000 gramos exactos no tampoco
pero nosotros más o menos el consumidor
pero la historia es que antes era un
objeto que pesaba un kilogramo que
estaba ahí pero como los objetos de
materia tienen bueno con el paso del
tiempo van perdiendo propiedades y tal
entonces para evitar que la referencia
desaparezca o cambie entonces ahora
hacen alusión a aún hay una
participación canadiense también en este
proceso de crear la cantidad de
científicos que había para el cambio de
la cuestión física
virtual era increíble no sabía que a
partir de francia pero también hay una
conexión con canadá que también acá
participaban si pones el kilogramo te va
a salir el reportaje significa si es un
estado aparato todo bueno y en todo y
pero es en el sistema métrico y no
reajustaron también el sistema inglés el
sistema
por eso cuando se metieron se salió del
break cité enseguida ese activo se salió
de la de la unión europea sevilla
inventó su break si está ahí entonces se
pusieron a salvo ahí estamos viendo la
información que decía leonora que en el
sitio nuestro para que los que quieren
ir a buscarlo lo pueden hacer
hay otras fotos que no sé si se puede
hacer andar eso es a veces más
complicado pero había la participación
canadiense está también ahí entonces más
preciso un kilogramo más precisos pero
con menos área que han inventado es una
maquinaria es impresionante lo que han
hecho para llegar a esa conclusión de
que con los el correr de los años se han
perdido no sé cuántos pero a nosotros no
nos afecta no nos afectan
me tranquilizo
le quitan un poco tranquilos de otras
cosas también les va a afectar exacto
imaginen compra 30 gramos de marihuana y
le dan 27
esto que ocurrió ayer porque me llamó
muchísimo la atención de este canadiense
de alberta se llama dan a me dice que
recorrió 22 mil kilómetros caminando por
canadá en 10 años
fráncfort grand
es impresionante y lo hizo bueno 22 en
uno alguno pues no sé si uno puede
imaginarse 22 mil kilómetros y lo que
hizo fue recorrer por primera vez un
canadiense en un recorrido llegamos a
los tres océanos al pacífico al
atlántico y finalizó en el océano ártico
que llegó ayer donde no me imagino pero
hacer eso durante diez años pues no
cualquiera no y él dice que un poco se
vio impulsado a hacerlo cuando su padre
en un momento dado que era un gran
caminante dejó de caminar las piernas no
le obedecían más y entonces él hizo la
promesa que el padre quería hacer esa
caminata y nunca pudo y le llevó diez
años diez años es decir por ahí paraba
también volvía columbia británica donde
trabajaba durante cuatro o cinco meses
juntaba dinero y continuaba
pensando a caminar 20 mil kilómetros
porque este señor también tenía
facebook tenía entonces iba contando su
historia dice que escribió tiene unos
libros cuadernos equivalente a un metro
entonces aparece distinta claro pero lo
que él dice es que era a través de todo
el canadá lo hizo por la trans
canadiense que ese es es una ruta que
comunica a los tres océanos del país
tranquilamente uno puede hacerlo no el
mejor en los tiempos y va empujando un
carrito no llevaba por sus cosas un
carrito con con eso yo lo vi también en
compostela hay gente que por ejemplo
tiene problemas en las rodillas no puede
caminar fuerte otro problema o no puede
cargar una mochila llevan unos carritos
que son como dos ruedas muy ágil y van
subiendo y lo van subiendo al ejército y
me impresionó he visto a gente que iba
más rápido que cualquiera caminando y
llevando su carrito con este señor
también llevaba su carrito con sus
pertenencias y lo que él decía que pudo
hacer ese viaje gracias a todas las
comunidades por donde pasaba que lo
acogían le daban
lo curaban este señor hasta se cayó se
golpeó la cabeza se desmayó en el hielo
tuvo problemas bueno lo hizo lo hizo y
realmente está y su historia ayer llegó
a los territorios del noroeste y ahí
terminó su periplo triste puede decir
que se dice que está contentísimo
es triste de terminar por muy contento
de volver con su familia
pero me impresionó me impresionó sobre
todo lo que habrá significado en los
inviernos canadienses esas caminatas a
40 bajo cero no porque todo eso lo hizo
y durante diez años diez inviernos sí
quedaron
ya comenzó a nevar ya estamos aquí en
invierno hoy empezó a la calle la piedra
ya no se mueve
algunos poquitos hubo algunos copitos el
el jueves no el miércoles creo sí pero
esta es la fuerza está la definitiva y
al invierno llegó la grada
no se va a rojos recuerdos del invierno
pasado que comenzó a nevar a finales del
mes de noviembre y que como siempre y
quedó la nieve el invierno
lo que me interesa lo bueno
no puede no podemos dejar de ver esto
del lado cómico básicamente porque es el
único refugio que queda y es este duelo
entre
iba a usar adjetivos
trump si entre entre trump y la prensa
cuando la casa blanca decide quitarle el
decide quitarle la credencial a jim
acosta y la bueno y es ahí esa posición
de trono
tipo una mala persona no debería estar
ahí qué vergüenza qué horror qué mala
gente que eres etcétera etcétera y la
reacción de cnn fue interesante porque
el llevaron a la casa blanca a la corte
que algo del mundo y lo que es también
interesante es que fox que es la
personalidad del trono del trump ismo
apoya a cnn claro se están curando en
salud porque mañana si entra un
demócrata también esto quería comer la
misma torta a ellos entonces y un juez
justamente hoy día
el juez timothy cal y le ordenó a la
casa blanca que reponga la credencial a
gemma costa
así que estoy segura que lo haga y si se
la dijo según la constitución la
enmienda tal y no sé que tienen no
pueden hacer eso y al habla la voz de la
portadora la portavoz de trump dijo sí
pero es ahí no se estipula que está
obligado el presidente a dejarla entrar
al edificio 20 le van a buscar la vuelta
o lo dejan entrar pero no responde a sus
preguntas lo ignora porque él es él es
el que escoge las personas que van a
hablar en la empresa dedazo que
funcionan que han habido casos en que
justamente periodistas pese al dedazo al
sant han logrado hacer que su pregunta
no solamente sea sea individual sino que
otros colegas de la prensa de la red
toman exacto entonces y había y había
periodistas que decían y por qué qué
pasa con el periodismo porque rayos no
se van todos lo dejan solo porque al
final es una es el cuerpo entero es eso
me imagino que son los grandes medios
también son los medios
detrás del periodista claro que de
alguna forma les impide o sea si yo me
imagino no sé si me pongo yo en su lugar
supongo que radio canadá en una
conferencia de prensa y que me levanté y
me vaya no sé cuál sería la reacción del
me voy a dijeron los medios otros medios
pero no como fox
creo que si bien algunos de ellos
indicaron que lo mejor que les pudo
ocurrir fue la llegada del trump porque
es un circo constante
hacer el trabajo con el tipo siempre
andan noticias haciendo escándalos cada
tweet suyo es como una como un paso de
pato por no decir otra cosa puedo decir
lo que hacen los patos cuando dan un
paso el siguiente paso bueno a mí lo que
me llamó la atención es que vi a que en
nuestro sitio de radio canadá de
personas que es que se divierten tomando
fotos pero tomando fotos de la desde
abajo de los puentes ah caramba aquí en
mante hará aquí en un poco por todos
lados en distintos lugares
y le toman fotos
debajo del puente y me llamó la atención
porque bueno yo suelo venir aquí en
bicicleta y estos son los puentes de
vancouver son todos en vancouver estos
son de vancouver también estos también
entonces me llamó la atención porque
como yo paso todos los días en bicicleta
debajo del puente jacques cartier y yo
había tomado una muy buena foto una foto
debajo del puente jacques cartier así
que entonces se la puedes mandar no más
radio canadá que es gente que la manda
sí sí me imagino no sé entonces pues ya
tendríamos una foto de debajo del puente
ya karting así que eso fue lo que me
llamó la atención y me dije bueno no soy
no soy solo yo el que anda tomando fotos
debajo de los pinos
yo tengo una por las ventanas y tú
tienes miles de sainte anne tengo
algo lleno de fotos de cientos y cientos
fotos de ventana en distintas ciudades
tipos ventanas
y efectivamente hay una lectura bastante
interesante cuando nos sacan la foto la
ventana porque aparte es lo que ve lo
que se ve y lo que no se ve de la
ventana y es ahí les voy a pasar para
que miren las fotos de mi ventana
fotos a puertas a puertas en varias
ciudades también sobre todo las me
gustan ver esas puertas donde conservan
esos adornitos esas manitos hay toda
serie de esculturas en metal de las
puertas antiguas no las van
desapareciendo en pueblos
portugal en bolivia en canadá a mí me
gustan los muros pero muros con plantas
trepadoras flores hay cada uno en todas
partes en cualquier parte del mundo me
encantan y los colores que pintan los
muros a veces son extraños
sí bueno leonardo y tenemos ahí algún
mensaje
nos está viendo alguien pidiendo a
buscar porque tenía una no todavía no
veo no veo aquí entonces aprovechamos
para mandarle un cordial saludo a javier
gonzález de garay cumple
a lo mejor está trabajando está en su
taxi y no está en una carrera y no nos
puede ver pero dejamos constancia que lo
haga como saludamos a todos los que nos
escuchan y que están acá escucha bien
nos está escuchando las mañanitas estos
son había listas que cantaba en seguida
vida a nuestro amigo que ahora hay allí
en las muchachas bonitas y hoy se las
cantamos a él como dice gonzález saludos
desde nicaragua gilberto martínez es
berta cáceres leonora qué gusto verte
vierte le felicito por el programa soy
mona
javier gonzález nungaray core desde 73 y
dos amigos lo mejor de lo mejor para
todos en el castor cibernético y dice
ser palacios nos pone buena canadá las
américas y un par de iconos de música
fotos y cosas que estamos de las que
estamos hablando de salud donde nos
escribes el palacio no sabría decirte
por qué todos los césar son de colombia
están césar augusto charlie
desde guadalajara bertha cáceres desde
santiago del estero dejar que mi nieta y
gilberto martínez
el cordial saludo a todos ustedes y
estamos muy contentos de que estén allá
del otro lado del micrófono y diferente
a sus pantallas bueno tenemos otros
comentarios a nuestros reportajes y la
ciencia dice es el ejército de canadá
levantaría requisitos de ciudadanía para
aumentar sus efectivos y eider ethier
lópez carlos dice buenos días soy
colombiano 25 años hacía parte de las
fuerzas militares de colombia pero por
amenazas de las guerrillas hacia mi
familia tuve que dejar mi posición y mi
pasión por la defensa de mi patria
dice he tomado la decisión de tratar de
ser parte de ustedes que son geniales
tanto como los 180 días de preparación
que se toma mi especialidad es tapar
tirador de alta precisión con
instrucción en el batallón de infantería
de caquetá quisiera caquetá
quisiera respuesta por parte del plantel
militar de canadá para saber qué
posibles tengo de ingresar es lo mejor
que puede hacer es dirigirse al ejército
canadiense al sitio web ves y te habla
tiene que hablar inglés o francés y que
haga todas las preguntas que necesite
una noticia que indica que el gobierno
canadiense decidió suavizar sus
exigencias porque parece que está
faltando también gente en el ejército
para las misiones de paz para lo que
fuera entonces
antes la exigencia de tener la
ciudadanía ahora siendo inmigrante puede
ser parte de las fuerzas armadas bueno
entonces y lo mejor que pueden hacer es
dirigirse al sitio del gobierno de
canadá a la embajada de canadá en el
país donde estén escribiendo y ahí piden
información
nosotros solo publicamos las noticias
pero no la transmisión la correa de
transmisión pero no podemos ayudar a
nadie en ese proceso sobre todo de
inmigración que es tan delicado y con el
cual canadá pues
y hay otro comentario en realidad parece
que estos todos son del mismo el mismo
la misma noticia el mismo palo digamos
en este caso el ejército canadá se
levanta en los siguientes requisitos y
johnny beltrán arias también ofrece sus
servicios y si estoy está dispuesto a
dar mi vida está cara música nada lo
necesita que los lugares en todo no
necesito dinero sólo servir en esta vida
al país que amo dice no ignoren este
mensaje no lo ignoramos estamos leyendo
ese sólo pido que me ayuden para llegar
a formoso países no tengo antecedentes
judiciales y policiales sólo quiero ser
útil y tener la posibilidad de ayudar a
los demás entiendan mis motivos dijo
dejó mis datos para que sean
certificados de la cual que la
obligación colombia y adriano y colombia
exija yo ni beltrán áreas y ayón y le
damos el mismo mensaje que ayer lópez la
posibilidad de entrar a canadá es
primero por el proceso de inmigración y
después la posibilidad de entrar al
ejército canadiense si logran entrar a
canadá como inmigrantes creo que es muy
interesante la opción d
de ese trabajo y visitar los sitios de
las embajadas en el país del embajada de
canadá en el país donde se encuentran
pero un comentario es una familia joven
de colombian tienen dos niños pequeños y
ellos dicen que están comentan que ya se
han refugiado en ecuador y están en este
momento bajo las alas de la acnur la
agencia de naciones unidas para los
refugiados y que han solicitado al acnur
que se los reciente y eligieron canadá
así que están esperando que sea
favorable su demanda su solicito agua en
eso ese ser otra de las posibilidades
también donde se puede pedir refugio en
los países donde se pueda pedir refugio
y la acnur en tratamiento no exacto rufo
valencia si aquí hay un comentario con
mucha ironía con mucha
muy cubana la cosa dice comentan esta
noticia sobre justamente el piloto que
despegó de monte habría visto un ovni
cerca de irlanda y gregorio dice todas
las audiencias que visitan cuba se
encuentran conexos terrestres a diario y
dos canadienses que visitan la cuba se
encuentran con extraterrestres a diario
uno de ellos es david ver que no sabe lo
que pasa en cuba el correo para
explicárselo todo bueno este es el
hincha
un chiste entre entre ellos y esto es
una novedad que todos los cubanos son
extraterrestres
aunque si yo soy nacido en argentina yo
la ciudadanía canadiense pasó a ver
estas fiestas también
y yo creo mucho con gente de otras
partes que
cuando habla con nosotros
como rayos vive la gente aquí y ayer se
lo imaginan más imágenes pero como baja
te integras bajo cero y que se paraliza
todo que pasa es que hay lugares donde
si se paraliza todo el tema es que
canadá es un país de invierno y es un
país desarrollado entonces ya tiene una
infraestructura prendió a ustedes yo me
levanté es al día antes de las 7 de la
mañana y ya la máquina había pasado
limpiando las veredas de nieve entre la
primera nevada cuanto habrá caído así
con más de 5 centímetros pasan bueno hay
lugares en eeuu rusos que se paraliza
completamente la ciudad
también se paraliza cuando caen más de
40 centímetros de nieve las escuelas
pero eso ya es casi un metro de manuel
trabajo no no no el trabajo pero uno
puede puede realizar a sentarse por por
la cuestión hay algunas veces que han
caído tormentas que se se preveía que
iba a haber no sé 40 centímetros 45
centímetros y nos dejaron salir ante el
trabajo eso verdad sí sí sí yo me
acuerdo
y por el trato exacto o sea
evidentemente hay momentos en los que
pasa es poca cosa es lo mismo que pasa
en en los emiratos árabes después de los
45 grados dan a suelto así
además asueto a todo el mundo no solo
asueto muerto yo tengo acá hablábamos de
cuba si de extraterrestre bueno no son
de extraterrestres estas cartas pero
seguimos recibiendo correo aéreo que nos
viene desde cuba no son mensajes
electrónicos y bueno pues queremos
acusar recepción basilio basilio mendoza
santos nos escribe desde ciego de ávila
no he abierto las cartas pero bueno
notificamos la reflexión esa próxima
semana
exacto rafael reyes plaza desde santiago
de cuba nos escribe rafael reyes
nuevamente maría odanis alarcón alcor
ahora nos escribe ella desde el río
grande río
auto granma cuba ayuda al mes
valdés nos escribe desde granma cuba y
bueno vamos a
para acá rafael reyes nuevamente nos
escribe de santiago de cuba acc usaremos
la recepción de las siguientes después
la goma de pegar en cuba es blindada
esas cartas no se abren más las
armadores o vamos a tomarnos el tiempo
de abrir los de espacio y lo especial
con estas cartas es que deben de poner
por acá
las estampitas las estampillas porque
todas
si alguien colección a alguien
coleccionista en la casa
y nos quita el placer a nosotros
en realidad hace años que no ejerzo pero
tengo una buena colección tengo en 1894
portugal y sería interesante ver estas
cubanas pero bueno no los podemos ver
las estampillas puestos
bueno para variar un poco vamos a
comenzar a hablar de los temas que
resaltamos esta semana y bueno vamos a
comenzar con título en ahora tú nos
hablas de una investigación sobre el
alzheimer y la música si uno dice
alzheimer de música y sabe que ya hay
muchísimas investigaciones que
investigaron se metieron ahí en el tema
de la música el cerebro de una persona
con demencia pero hay algo nuevo que ha
surgido y esto fue llevado a cabo por
corinne fisher que es directora de la
clínica de trastornos de la memoria en
el hospital sant michael de toronto y
por una eminencia canadiense en el tema
de música y alzheimer michael todd que
es el autor principal de la
investigación y profesor de música y
neurociencia en la universidad de
toronto y lee lo que descubrieron
primero hicieron una investigación con
20 personas con leve muy leve que recién
empezaban a tener alzhéimer problemas
cognitivos muy leves
y le hicieron el experimento siguiente
hicieron les pidieron que encontraran
música que a esas personas les gustaba
hace 30 años atrás cuando nosotros
cuando te enamoras y siempre hay una
canción cuando en fin cuando nace un tu
hijo hay música bueno entonces les
hicieron escuchar música desconocida o
que nada que ver con ellos y a través de
los escáners que hicieron en el cerebro
vive en la zona que se activa siempre
cuando uno escucha música pero cuando
les hicieron escuchar la música que
ellos escuchaban cuando eran jóvenes y
que tiene un significado para ellos
emocional tiene que ver con su vida hay
otras zonas que se van activando en el
cerebro que se van conectando entonces
lo que les hicieron hacer a estas
personas durante dos semanas les
hicieron escuchar la música que ellos
eligieron una hora por día durante dos
semanas pero había que haber había que
hacer una escucha activa entonces por
ejemplo esa persona tenía que recordar
asociar con los recuerdos porque es lo
que les recordaba pero además comentarlo
eso y asia con la familia con los amigos
o con los gente que los cuidaba si
estaban en alguna institución entonces
lo se hacían hablar sobre esa música y
los recuerdos que tenían y se dieron
cuenta que después de dos semanas el
cerebro había desarrollado unas áreas se
había expandido más todo eso por escáner
y se dieron cuenta que las personas que
tenían una mejor memoria y también
descubrieron que la música cuando tienes
alzhéimer en realidad esa parte del
cerebro que se activa con esa música no
está no es que sea especial sino que no
está afectado y citada por el alzhéimer
entonces no es tanto la música en sí
sino la música con el entorno con las
emociones y entonces definitivamente se
dieron cuenta que había una mejora
cognitiva de esas personas eso es lo
nuevo y lo interesante además esto están
presentando la hora en eeuu en un
congreso de alzheimer que dicen que va
un poco a revolucionar un poco los trata
y lo interesante de esto lo que decía el
doctor este michael todd es que si
tienen alguien en la familia que está
empezando a tener problemas de demencia
que se olvida palabras de lugares
busquen música que esa persona escuchaba
y hágala hablar hagan el mismo ensayo es
muy fácil y que hablen que hablen y que
cuenten sus emociones quieres recuerda
la música y que van a ver que hay una
mejora cognitiva de esas personas y no
lo no dejen de hacerlo entonces como que
se están no sé si desarrollando nuevas
áreas en el cerebro o están recuperando
viejas áreas de eso yo no lo puedo decir
pero si parece que está dando resultado
y lo interesante lo más interesante creo
que bueno está dada la receta un grupo
de aplicar sin necesidad de dar médico
hacerlo con tu familia con tus amigos
pero tienes que contar o sea tu música
vos
te enamoraste a los 20 años y esa música
te trae que recuerdos porque qué hacías
en ese momento de quién te enamoraste
con esa música y finalmente lo que dicen
son esas emociones las que están
activando el cerebro y lo están
desarrollando o sea que el remedio para
esto sería pues hay que documentar a
toda la gente las guitarreadas
yo he escuchado gente que dice que es lo
que uno tiene que hacer por ejemplo es
y cambiarlo las estructuras fijas por
ejemplo yo vengo caminando siempre por
el mismo lugar del trabajo un día ir por
otra y prestar atención a la otra calle
en mi casa yo siempre cuelgo la toalla
de la misma manera doblarla y colgarla
de otra manera
dar vuelta al papel higiénico para que
no quede hacia abajo sino hacia arriba o
sea elementos que cambian la rutina que
hacen que el cerebro tenga una de
repente se sorprende exacto esa mira yo
voy a leer solo la partecita está para
que quede claro lo que dicen los médicos
después de este experimento dice lo que
descubrimos fue que hubo una mejora en
la conectividad funcional del cerebro
cambios en la activación del cerebro y
también mejoras en las puntuaciones de
la memoria lo que nos dijo que al
exponer el cerebro repetidamente a esta
música familiar la gente estaba
mejorando cognitivamente y había
evidencia de que su cerebro también
estaba cambiando
este ejercicio lo hacen en cualquier
momento con la familia con los amigos es
gratis y la de la gente que quiere
seguir leyendo todo el contenido acá les
digo pueden ir a la página de internet
redesigned punto sea barra s de español
buscar alzheimer haya ahí o entrando
cuando uno entra en cualquier artículo
aquí dice categoría y autor si buscan a
leonora chapman ahí van a salir todos
sus artículos y el artículo de la página
está ahí en esta sociedad en que las
parejas y las familias se hacen si
racing y se juntó incluso juntas no sólo
acá rufo bueno hay pero quizá más acá
que haya porque ella por ejemplo quién
es quién
hay menos hay obviamente hay menos
uniones libres que acá no hay una
tendencia cada vez más pero no es igual
por ciento no tiene y en él es campeona
que ve que es cambiarse lo que quiero de
simplemente es que hay justamente
hablando de hábitos hay parejas que
entran en crisis justamente porque
cuando empieza a vivir juntos es donde
la música no no el uno aprieta en la
pasta de dientes desde abajo mientras
otra persona
la apreta del medio
[Risas]
y no se puede vivir 5 claro que tu
esposa le importa un comino
[Risas]
aunque impresionante revelación porque
también hay quienes agarran la cosa del
lado digamos más cómico este es el tipo
que sabe que su mujer lo está engañando
con amigos y viene y va a haber al amigo
y le dice oye si tú eres el amante de mi
mujer tú y yo que venimos siendo
[Risas]
la próxima semana su cumpleaños que le
regalamos
bueno rupo habló es mencionábamos al
principio
en lo que decía leonardo a 9000 y tú nos
presenta justamente a ese canadiense que
le prestó la voz a esta gran computadora
y justamente fue una sorpresa saber que
era un canadiense un actor gen ha sido
muy directo clearing quien le dio la voz
a la computadora y que justamente ahora
que por ejemplo estamos ahora podemos
hablar con nuestros teléfonos le
preguntas por cualquier cosa por ejemplo
para afrontar que está haciendo
cualquier acto de buenos aires
a veces sin preguntarle nada no oye si
está activada buenos aires
y entonces está lindo entonces para
comernos hábito escuchando esta voz no
sabe qué bueno por lo menos este momento
sabemos que es una voz robotizada una
road de un programa entonces esta
película que se hace el 68 este actor
canadiense le da la voz a la computadora
hub y una tono que realmente quien ha
visto esa película en esa época pues es
se olvidan de esta película
está la voz y lo que es interesante es
que fui a buscar la comparación por
ejemplo a la traducción al español y el
español era hecha por españoles
no se puede entonces quería destacar
justamente eso eso y esa película no que
justamente ahora que tenemos las las
tabletas que tenemos teléf internet
etcétera todo eso ya estaba en esa
película y justamente las voces y lo que
es interesante que he buscado
si alguna compañía o alguna empresa
tenemos la hoja y escuchar si podemos
escuchar
es compra tan de las de
a ver si se escucha
se escucha por ventana de la nave se
escucha ahí viene día la madre en la
nave que vivimos el héroe
justo a la parte que no habla
pero si hablas puertas a una puerta
me puedes escuchar
claudio m
al hacer mosquita muerta
[Música]
yo no he dejado
se volvió muy turbio justo en la cama
efe
[Música]
as
y dejar que la ponga en peligro entonces
cinco minutos entonces se pueda ver la
película y pues interesante cooperar con
la versión en español no lo he visto yo
he visto rambo por ejemplo en español
doblada en españa porque españa tiene
una ley de doblaje muy especial si la
película por ejemplo es argentina debe
ser doblada al español la colombiana
debe ser doblada al español de españa
no no no no
hay cines donde se ve con subtítulos
pero esa es la ley
leonardo gimeno y tú nos habla en un
tema que te debe dejar escéptico a ti
mismo porque un sustituto vegetal de la
carne para un carnívoro como tú que
comenzar a decirse 60 días por año 1 360
y 150 y 960
y no la historia es si llega a suceder y
llegar a encontrar el gusto yo también a
mí también me pone mal cuando veo como
sacrifican a los animales para que
nosotros podamos comer o sea si llegan a
lograr el sustituto a cómo se sacrifican
los animales para que nosotros comemos
como los sacrifican ellos no se
sacrificará nada a mí me encantaría
bueno la historia es que un un
investigador italiano que está haciendo
buenos su última parte o continúa sus
estudios en barcelona género desarrolló
una impresora 3d que imprime carne
fantástico
proteínas vegetales
y está imprimiendo carne y va
imprimiendo está en fase de un proceso
de ajustarlo y de lograr lo que uno le
falta porque ya existen hamburguesas de
poros
y ese tipo de cosas lo que no engaña al
paladar del buen comedor de carne es no
la textura claro la textura la textura y
él es lo que está haciendo es justamente
eso está trabajando este experimentos y
trabajando la textura y parece que ha
logrado algo bastante interesante por
ahora en realidad en el artículo dice
que parecen bifes liliputienses porque
son este tamaño pero que imprimir 100
gramos de carne vegetal con una
impresora 3d cuesta aproximadamente 3
dólares o sea que tampoco es caro en el
caso de bueno aquí la carne es casi
primitiva al siglo entonces tres dólares
ese mismo pero eso es cuando lo está
probando y es una sola impresora aunque
cuando vaya a nivel industrial es muy
probable que esos gastos centros sean
mucho menores
bueno la historia es lograr el gusto de
esta combinación para participar en la
investigación
ya está en contacto con chefs
internacionales para lograr lo que le
falta que es un poco el gusto distintivo
de cada uno de los cortes por ejemplo
pero se hace y se imprime carne para
comer con carbón y como le dan el gusto
se puede hacer a la parrilla y con el
mismo gustito el mismo proceso digamos
de cocción de la carne probablemente se
obtenga un gusto similar así que bueno
ahí vamos
el futuro nos lleva a la carne sintético
en el 4 de mayo vamos a comer asados o
hamburguesas de chapulines
ese es también uno de los de la materia
prima para la proteína proteína de los
insectos en que es extraordinaria en el
tiempo se nos va como agua entre los
dedos muy rápidamente yo los invité
escuchar una entrevista que hice con la
cineasta quebequense nadine gómez y es
en este momento se está llevando a cabo
aquí en montreal los encuentros
internacionales del documental de
montreal y ella nadie presentó su
película el viernes hoy esta noche pasa
esa película que se llama exarchia el
canto de los pájaros exarchia es un
barrio de atenas un barrio de atenas que
es muy combativo un barrio anarquista y
fue allí donde en exarchia donde en 1967
comenzaron todas las protestas de que
llevaron al golpe de estado de los
coroneles
en ese evento
y después de eso pues que terminó en el
esta época de los coroneles y después en
el 2008 en las revueltas que hubo en el
2008 en grecia y bueno pues ella está
cineasta se pasea en una noche por las
distintas en una calle de ese barrio y
va agarrando testimonios de las personas
de artistas de pasantes de todo tipo
todas las personas que van encontrando y
pues nos muestra un retrato de ese
barrio de atenas que en el que además de
esto
reciben a los migrantes de los flujos de
inmigrantes que va llegando a atenas van
a exarchia entonces pues es interesante
ver cómo reacciona la gente frente al
estado de la economía y cómo reacciona
pues frente a la inmigración no entonces
pues eso es todo lo que les les podría
decir es con respecto a esta película ya
ese reportaje eres ynet puntos ya en
todos nuestros
para consultar todos nuestros temas en
los controles técnicos hoy chantal en su
hogar muchísimas gracias a todos ustedes
allá del otro lado del micrófono nos
agradece el saludo y con todo gusto con
mucho placer por supuesto y bueno y le
recordamos que el audio de este programa
tendrá la música del grupo o que son
unas cubanas que viven en toronto y que
están estuvieron anoche en espectáculos
aquí en mostrar eso fue todo chau adiós
adiós